president trump is pressing ahead with
his effort to overturn joe biden's
presidential election victory
despite court ruling after court ruling
that upholds the election outcome
on friday mr trump suffered yet another
legal setback when
three republican appointed judges
offered a stinging rebuke to his
campaign's push
to challenge the results in pennsylvania
trump campaign lawyers are threatening
to take their fight to the supreme court
at the same time mr trump is making new
demands on what it will take for him to
step down
on inauguration day january 20th ben
tracy is at the white house this morning
ben good morning
ed good morning so president trump is
now demanding that president-elect joe
biden prove that he
actually won the election and while the
president and his campaign continue to
say the election was rigged
judges continue to say they have no
proof
you're going to find tremendous fraud
you're going to find fraud of hundreds
of thousands of votes
per state but no one has found
widespread fraud of any kind
not even president trump's lawyers and
his campaign suffered another legal
defeat friday in one of its final
attempts to overturn
joe biden's win in pennsylvania in a
searing opinion a trump appointed
federal judge
wrote that calling an election unfair
does not make it so
charges require specific allegations and
then proof
we have neither here an inner rebuke of
the campaign's legal team he wrote
voters not lawyers choose the president
it was a rigged election
so we have to figure it out president
trump is not conceding
before hitting the golf course friday he
hit president-elect biden on twitter
bizarrely claiming that biden can only
enter the white house as president
if he can prove that his ridiculous 80
million votes
were not fraudulently or illegally
obtained twitter immediately flagged the
tweet
thank you georgia go out and vote with
just 53 days left in office
president trump will return to the
campaign trail next weekend
stumping for two republicans in senate
runoff races in georgia
that will decide control of the u.s
senate and while he won't say if he will
attend president-elect biden's
inauguration on january 20th
he's already focused on one part of his
legacy a coronavirus vaccine
likely to be widely distributed during
the first year of
biden's administration don't let him
take credit
for the vaccines because the vaccines
were me and i pushed people
harder than they've ever been pushed
before the trump campaign continues to
push its lawsuit saying it will appeal
its defeat in pennsylvania all the way
to the u.s supreme court
but given that no judge so far has found
any merits to the campaign's claims
the supreme court may not even take the
case michelle
thank you